it's coming from a youtuber i decided to
go out and uh troll a little bit this is
what happened so during the summer time
there's this big fair in minnesota it's
called valley fair so i got the uniform
for here i think the plan is that i'm
going to wear the sweatshirt over the
uniform kind of ease our way into it
a whole lot of buffoonery also the guy
that gave me the uniform said he
literally got fired from here because
they planted like a 10 bill on the
ground and he picked it up and they
fired his ass if that's any indication
of how strict they are we're gonna be
out of here quick bro i love when groups
of people just started staring at me but
won't say anything look at it
my boys
yeah can we be in it you gotta drop to
your knees in bag
what the [ __ ] are you not mad at now
yeah listen if any of our subscribers do
this [ __ ] i swear to god i'll pretend
you don't exist don't do don't do this
i'll tell you to unsubscribe
i'll put you in a video just to shame
you i will walk away real quick don't do
that corny [ __ ] have some self-respect
don't do that [ __ ] ladies if you want to
suck some dick to get on your knees i'm
down with that but don't do this
i respect you a lot ladies shut the [ __ ]
up
what huh i respect women what it's
consensual absolutely okay so that's me
respecting them if they want to get on
their knees to explore their sexual
liberation who am i to judge
she has made a decision as a independent
woman living in the west she has decided
hey i don't get on my knees for jesus
i get on my knees for the penis
you know what exactly and me yeah you're
right
yes he has he has understood the
knowledge has entered his cranium
he has he has grasped the lace
that we are trying to spread
he's cutting in line why'd you cut the
line
why'd you cut the line i'm talking to my
cousin no you're not going
no i watched you though you cut the
whole line i'm talking all these people
are waiting for their kids to get off
they're not no but i've been waiting
this whole time it's crazy
you can't get out here are you too tall
what are you talking about yes i can
you can't get on
are you discriminating against me
because i'm tall
all right
so they left right like this guy
he's been a useless troll yeah yeah yeah
okay you being a troll all right pete
you know i mean you can ask him but he's
not going to let you here right you're
too tall no but some of us are waiting
and like out there all day and she just
cut the line
i thought that was you i thought you
were next to me i looked over it's not
guys over at uh the kids area recently
the kids area we had a description of
well two white guys and a black guy i'm
half white
he's still trolling with that trolley
yeah he's no trolling
broken
victim didn't really take it off no
what they said uh yeah you guys grabbed
her you got a camera that's why i'm
thinking that
we grabbed her whoa whoa we're gonna go
take you guys back so she can see if she
can identify you and then we got spd
coming too so
what are you talking who do we grab
i just got the report so
this has got this is going to be way out
of proportion yo grab out of proportion
i don't have to wait for anything are we
under arrest no but you're not going to
scare girls
yeah so we'll leave the park then i'm
not staying here with people like
accusing us of
what did we do we're gonna bring up to
the front and then we get the person to
come see if they can identify which way
is the exit
is that is that the exit where's the
exit
he said this is the exit nobody said hey
no [ __ ] it ain't no and you work
security no you're not out of town you
got a gun but your security yeah you try
to deceive them to go there so you could
hold them on the premises
listen security cops security cops
because he has a gun that's why
i call them that because they really
think they're cops sometimes security
cops and cops do the same thing they
gonna lie they don't lie
in order to get what they want they are
gonna lie
so you guys are wondering wait why is
this guy leaving if he did nothing wrong
first off the cops the security already
lied to him he already liked him to get
him to go somewhere would you just trust
a random person like that that doesn't
even have a badge that doesn't have to
do nothing i'm not trusting you
and also if you know you didn't touch
the [ __ ] then you extra man i'm not
going to go through this whole process
if i don't have to
you guys saw it on video he was trolling
and you could say they get rid of these
people off the premises ain't got a
problem but when she claimed that a real
crime was committed understand how
different it is and these guys trying to
lead them somewhere to make them seem
like they got an issue so sexual assault
that's big
that's me and you got it on time
i am
sueing the whole place
a man are you saying that you
got sexually
is that what you're saying
and then she just goes
well i felt like [ __ ] you felt what no
but we don't know hold on hold on hold
on let's watch if for me i don't know if
you watch the video hold on
i don't know if it's the girl lying or
if it's the officer lying or the person
that transmitted the report to the
office i don't know who
i i don't know who can i ask you can i
ask you this is a serious question
at what point does an officer come out
of nowhere or a security guard say you
sexually assaulted someone without
someone saying that to them
it happens i i do not trust them either
no
i've never heard a police officer come
out of nowhere on behalf of a victim who
didn't come forward
that doesn't happen they don't a cop
doesn't just see you in the street and
say you assaulted this guy yes it does
happen it happened to me
i'm usually chill but you can't [ __ ]
walk up and accuse us of
get the [ __ ] out of it what's your name
dan i'm the director of security a lot
of people don't have something to say
about you dan all i ask you guys is to
hold on so we can sit here and get this
script no i'm not holding on for anybody
yeah she grouch dude she touched us so
now you were there you just said you
didn't have anything to do with it yeah
we we were there we didn't grab anybody
it's all on camera detective dude why
are you so mad because you're walking
away from me and i just admitted you
were there we're not under arrest so i
don't need to listen to you we didn't do
anything we didn't do [ __ ] we literally
have it all on
video why can't you just resolve it i'm
not staying here to explain a situation
that we didn't do anything wrong they
brought back up too you can't just say
we did something based off of a report
we didn't do [ __ ] based on a report oh
you can't you deny you were even there
then you said you were there and she
grabbed we have the entire thing on
camera that's that's the funny part what
are you doing
why is there three of them you guys
brought up the whole avengers for this
come over here in the security office
why don't we not if you're innocent
they'll tell you what why don't we not
shut the hell up you're not getting away
from front of the line pass you accused
us of sexual assault why don't you want
to talk now you're not now you're going
to apologize
after trying to hold him on the premises
this whole time says oh no let me open
the door and escort you out just to get
the little last word in get the [ __ ] out
of here bro so you see the [ __ ] out but
you see how he's lying and he's being i
don't even know
listen trust me there are some people
working security they receive a report
and they knew they need they know their
security they don't have a tara ta for
nothing
they will do the extra mile to lie
to get you in there just to get you in
there because they got they got you to
do trust me not only i've worked there
i've seen it happen and it happened to
me
they will take matters into their own
hands knowing that there's a disturbance
and they will implement [ __ ] i'm not
saying that this has happened but i can
believe that it is and at this point i
don't know if it's the lady the dude or
the organization it could be any [ __ ]
body let me ask you do you believe the
lady didn't initiate this it's possible
i'm saying so you think she didn't say
nothing this guy just came out of
nowhere what i'm saying no i'm asking do
you think that's a possibility you think
that without her even saying anything
that's not what i said but i'm gonna ask
you no no no no that's not what i said
so no i don't think it just happened
like that okay so you you do understand
that she initiated this right yeah okay
so that's all i think the way you may
started before you made it sound like
she may not be involved that's not what
i said what i said is she said some [ __ ]
right and then he escalated and
yesterday and he just brewed some other
[ __ ] and had his [ __ ] on top of that you
haven't been like you know what hey let
me go get it
i'll meet you halfway that i can see
kind of clicked for me in that maybe the
girl just said yo these guys were
following me around and the security's
already been tired of these guys so they
escalated the thing which
i could see happening that's a
possibility the other other possibility
is the woman overreact to what happened
and she said these guys harassed us and
followed us yeah and maybe there was a
miscommunication there but i'm not ready
to pin this on the lady on the dude on
the organization i don't know what the
[ __ ] happened so i can't be like this
lady is [ __ ] up i can't be i can't say
that i've seen way too many officers
[ __ ] up way too many security guards
[ __ ] up okay so i don't know i don't
know who's who and what does what but
i'm just saying anything is possible
front-of-the-line passes for the
inconvenience get out of here it's not
an inconvenience you accused us of a
felony
that's not an inconvenience he's the guy
that gets rejected from the police
academy and then goes and power trips on
everybody you know me if you're fans of
this channel i don't lose my temper like
that but you don't [ __ ] walk up and
accuse somebody that and then he noticed
he started to backtrack at the end
because he knows we have it all on
camera we can give you front of the line
passes for the inconvenience it's not an
inconvenience people get their lives
ruined from that he's not lying
everything he said was facts he said
that's insulting to me that you accused
me of some crazy crime like that and
trying to get me from the line passes
that's a spit in my face oh i think
you're a very deplorable person maybe oh
i was wrong well do you want to come
back to our establishment and cut the
line
you what the [ __ ] do you take me for
and that's what they do what the [ __ ] do
you take me for that's what the [ __ ] and
you all know how [ __ ] embarrassing
and insulting it is to be accused of
some [ __ ] like that when you did
nothing
i've been there
i've been there got the t-shirt
and then they try to come back at you
with some [ __ ] [ __ ] uh remedy
talk about oh i'll let you get the [ __ ]
out of here my boy love was snapping on
his ass bro like what
what is he talking about i was gonna get
my hair dyed blue too and now i don't
even think i want to she touched us
and then and then the guy tries the
security tries to like use that against
us he's like oh well they just admitted
that they were there we have it all on
film valley fair is officially on
my list of most hated companies it's up
there with burger king it might have
passed burger king honestly guys what's
up nothing much hang on a second so
anything a problem yeah what's going on
today
they walked up and accused us of sexual
assault is that the security guy from
earlier no it is
we have the whole thing on camera we
didn't do anything i don't know much i'm
just trying to look into it trying to
get both sides of the story too you're
worried about recording everything's
recording right here as well are we
under arrest or no we're just being so
we can leave that we can leave there
being detained really to look into
something if you want to get rough like
that i'm not getting i'm not getting
rough you have an id with you yeah break
it out why are we being detained we're
looking into something okay all right
listen no if you're suspected of
something in this case you can't just
walk away no in this case you the police
there
give the idea break out break out the id
they you haven't done anything i
understand
very [ __ ] frustrated
although you're being
underestimated investigation you're not
being detained
you're under investigation and they need
to investigate why are we being detained
we're looking into something i don't
think we committed a crime for us to be
asked questions for our ideas okay are
we free to go well then you can go to
jail if you'd like if you're not gonna
identify yourself i'll identify myself
but like i'm confused
difficult that's fine we can do that i'm
not trying to be difficult i'm really
not okay and you don't have an idea on
you at all okay what about you he's dead
he's deaf let me grab it because while
it's in the car all i know is valley
fair security called us to look into
something all right i don't know what's
going on there's two sides to every
story i know that doing his job for a
long time we're waiting to get more
information from here and see what's
going on okay on your point of view what
happened
nothing nothing like we have it all on
camera the term that you guys just are
accused of with
nothing of that of that sort happened
nothing happened there's no reason why
we would stop you no there's no reason
why you would accuse us of that okay so
you guys tell me what happened here what
was going on that caused this issue to
arise in us being here i'm genuinely
like confused at what situation because
like we walked up and talked to somebody
that was waiting for a ride that's the
only thing i can think of we didn't
touch anybody we have it all on camera
we didn't touch anybody so much about
touching they said uh yeah you guys
grabbed her we didn't say anything like
sexual or anything
i asked her why she cut the line i said
why'd you cut the line
that we've got because he said that we
touched somebody and we
pretty good that's what he the head of
security said
and we did not put hands on anybody
again i'm coming into this at the end
here trying to sort it out and all this
and all this [ __ ]
the cop is the right one to me
in all this [ __ ] the cop is really
trying to [ __ ] level he's just i'm
just trying
to know what the [ __ ] is going on i
think everyone's watching this and say
i never heard preach say that before but
i give it when i have to give to give it
the cop is not even giving assumptions
or nothing what happened
what happened that's exactly what you
want and the attitude that he has he's
just like man
what's up
tell me what's up there's two sides of
the story tell me yours that's it so to
me in this
[Music]
not trying to accuse anybody of anything
but i'm merely going off of what i'm
told i'm glad you didn't even say the
words and stuff but that that other guy
the way he approaches was just not it
was not
okay it's not okay so in your guys's
eyes nothing happened no how about him i
know he's got earbuds in and he's deaf
allegedly you said can we get your
attention is he really deaf or is he
just playing that he's like partially
deaf it's hard for him to hear do you
know how to sign he's good
what's this caution hot moms their wet
moms thing it's just merch you like it
yeah i need to get you a shirt man yeah
i wish i had an extra shirt you want
this shirt loaf you wanna fit me man
just hit the gym a little bit i got a
good gym program you can hear too i'm
good man
you wild
but if i but it there was a lot of cuts
i don't know if it was all in jokes and
[ __ ] yeah it was or whatever it was
whatever i don't know what maybe he's
gonna take it well that's a while but
that's why that's why listen we also
grew up in the air like don't be saying
no crazy [ __ ] to cops so that's why so
that comment that's why i mean maybe
that's what i come from a different era
so whatever but that
hey
i'm going out of proportion i'm the
lawyer
why are we still
here being detained for an investigation
right now simple as that okay so valley
fair needs to do their thing whatever
they want to do with them and then
they're good there's nothing criminal
for us so do your thing whatever you
need hey i want a one year pass i want a
one year free pass bro no [ __ ] you're
not going back to this place you're not
giving no money let me get this straight
the cop just said there's nothing
criminal so what so
ugh
so there's nothing evil that happened
they dropping it what they checked the
cameras is that what happened
nothing a false accu accuse us of
and then we're not getting a free pass
[ __ ] that bro i had to call my lawyer
over this [ __ ] and i'm i'm pissed off
where are you mad at i'm mad at dumb not
y'all y'all doing your job
which
like i said that's why we were hanging
out waiting to figure out what happened
and we don't put people in jail they
don't deserve to go to jail you're a
good guy so
we we have to chat can i can i give you
a hug
see it's off it's our game so now i'm
coming
without me
i don't get no love
hey man you get this workout program for
free
that's what that's right
this is my homie right here six hundred
and seventy six thousand hey he you he's
gonna be on youtube he said i gotta let
my kids know i'm still cool in these
streets what about me
what about me
i'm a good cop too
i put you in jail come on here give big
papa a hug
he heard how many subscribers hey hey
hey listen we got 1.7 you know i'm
saying i better start getting comp
passes too
you don't even go outside shut the [ __ ]
up but if i do you know i'm gonna start
walking around there and she'd be like
yeah yeah
i need my id
oh here's my youtube account
you know i already
already did that right what the youtube
[ __ ] oh yeah i didn't do it but yeah
someone [ __ ] like you don't know him
he's famous and everything except stop
it stop while i'm being stopped by the
cop off yeah and the couple's like oh
yeah who he is then you start looking at
me you know
yo stop telling that we got 1.7 million
subscribers on youtube stop it stop
telling me one of the hottest [ __ ] of
2021. stop
stop time that our videos girls over
500k park
i got to get you a shirt bro i'm just
starting up
i like how he's whispering over there
like can we get him a formal trespass
please like he's [ __ ] well you guys
are going to be dressed big guy added to
the list man i don't care about being
trespassed but i'm not coming back here
this has the worst
customer service and security i've ever
seen appreciate you for really doing
your job you're fair on both sides it's
bigger than black and white so i
understand that you're aware of that
yeah
all right
the resolutions they got banned from the
spot they got banned for the spot yeah
they're bad they can never go back to
the red valley which is fine they don't
want to admit they're wrong doing
nothing so they're not going to do that
of course not as far as who are you guys
that i will expose the [ __ ] out of you
yes
which is what i would expose the [ __ ] so
if y'all feel some type of way you guys
can look up the valley fair with
minnesota it was minnesota valley fair
okay you know reviews are a thing you
know what i'm saying uh hashtag you
rah-rah
minnesota valley fair i mean listen i'm
not telling you guys to go out there and
review bomb them to one side i'm not
saying that don't don't
all this to say all this to say this i
don't know if it was a security guard
like preach mention or if it was a lady
but again it's just one of those things
that like
all i know is guilt is assumed men lie
women lie
guilt is assumed that's it so i don't
know my man was trolling annoying sure
what did you accuse him of what grabbing
a [ __ ] out of here
that's [ __ ] up i'm glad they ended on
a comedic note and found some humor in
there so shout outs to them
anything else no
let us know what you guys think